this video is brought to you by
surfsharkvpn
[Music]
hey wisecrack michael here and today
we're talking about the boys
the show is sadistic and hilarious and
has plenty to say about the superhero
genre and modern day america but as we
watch season 2 we kept coming back to
one question
are any of these characters for real
when stormfront or billy or homelander
talk about things they ostensibly care
about
are they just faking it and if so why
all the posturing
let's find out in this wisecrack edition
on the boys season 2
and of course spoilers ahead
but before we get into it i want to give
a shout out to this week's sponsor
surfsharkvpn it's no secret that you
don't have much privacy on the internet
these days
however there is a way that you can
protect yourself online and that is by
using a vpn
a vpn sends your information through an
encrypted tunnel so you can safely use
your passwords without the fear of
hackers stealing your
information a vpn can also protect you
from targeted ads and other pesky data
trackers
when you use surfsharkvpn you can use
your account on any of your devices
so you know you're always protected they
have over a thousand servers in 63
countries and offer additional features
if you use the link in the description
and use the promo code wisecrack in
december
you can get surfsharkvpn for 84 off its
normal annual price
plus four extra months for free go to
surfshark.deals
wisecrack or hit the link in the
description protect yourself online and
download surfsharkvpn today
and now for a quick recap the boys is
the story of one billy butcher and his
crew of vigilante misfits were trying to
take down
the vaught corporation a very evil
company that employs and contracts out
the services of
often evil superheroes what happens if
uh i don't know i do
and now this just another useless blind
guy
it's important to note that these
superheroes aren't some happy accident
r.i.p to bob ross but the result of
vaught's very secretive
definitely illegal medical experiments
on children the boys
try to expose vaught and save billy's
wife and her child from their head soup
homelander
season 2 also introduces the latest
vaught hero stormfront who turns out to
be an
actual century-old nazi heinrich
he was a lovely dancer if it seems like
the boys is full of people espousing
disingenuous politics and posturing for
the cameras
it's because the show goes to great
lengths to show us how almost
every character is constantly performing
after all it's not enough to simply be a
hero in this world
you have to play a hero too superhero
star in movies
title card dawn of the seven go on talk
show circuits
stormfront congrats on the seven are you
as excited to be here as i am
i don't know i don't think so and even
give those lame midnight religious
infomercials but thanks to the church of
the collective
i now know the kind of man i want to be
hey dude
that's not cool heck even when they're
not on the screen
they worry about public approval ratings
so at a i'm
down a point one and a half two and
fastidiously try to keep their personal
selves in check
oh my god everyone is so [ __ ] stage
managed
life isn't actually a pr strategy you
can say what you think
and it's not just our superheroes who
are constantly putting on a show
whether it's becca playing house with a
sociopathic superman
or congresswoman victoria newman
whipping her base into a
frenzy every character seems to put on a
mask at one time
or another so here's the question
wisecrack
what do you think happens when these
deliberate performances collide with hot
button social issues
well we've got a term for you virtue
signaling
now before you smash that dislike button
hear me out
virtue signaling is a term that gets
thrown around to suggest that people are
disingenuously engaging with social
issues not out of genuine concern but to
promote their own self-image
while it's certainly a real phenomenon
it's basically become a catch-all term
to call
anyone who cares about anything a fraud
one might say that even
my discussion of virtue signaling is in
itself some kind of signal avert you
about how wise i am in an effort
to make wisecrack seem trey woke and
then if you get mad at that and tweet
about it your righteous indignation
could itself
be some virtue signaling to your
impassioned fans
the point is it's very easy to call just
about
anything virtue signaling and it's also
often but not always
a lazy and incoherent argument and it's
confusing because we live in a world
where we don't trust
anyone to stand for anything for the
right reasons and the boys takes this
confusion
head on the boys is centrally concerned
not with how ordinary people display
their support of social issues but how
corporations do
in turn it explores how ordinary people
end up consuming information about those
ideas
in season one for instance vaught
rebrands their hero starlight
as a feminist icon she transforms
embraces her feminine strengths
goodbye yellow brick road and hello
starlight
except well their brand of female
empowerment through sexuality
isn't exactly what the budding superhero
had in mind
but doesn't care they're more concerned
with the image of an empowered woman
that people can also ogle
than you know actually empowering anyone
most importantly
it tells the story of your
transformation
of what you're going through how exactly
do you know
what i'm going through exactly aka
virtue signaling the starlight
rebranding helps their bottom line
rather than any feminist cause a similar
conflict happens in season two
homelander maliciously outs queen maeve
who
in the seven is gay queen wave revealing
her ex-girlfriend whom maeve is then
forced to pretend is her current lover
vaught reimagines maeve's forced outing
in their film dawn of the seven
as a wholesome coming out story complete
with a cliched love interest in the form
of a counter culture computer hacker i'm
afraid to
to show the world who i am yeah
so who are you maeve i'm gay after
establishing maeve as a queer icon
vaught capitalizes on it to sell like
this
brave made pride box because you can't
be proud
on an empty stomach it's worth noting
that while
maeve bars are sadly fictitious this
whole using someone's identity for
profit
is a fairly common advertising strategy
while you're head of digital marketing
may
genuinely care about say racism their
message is still getting filtered
through the lens of
what's going to make us money as a
result most companies only support
social issues
after they become massively popular and
therefore
safe like how shampoo conglomerate
l'oreal posted about standing with the
black community this summer despite
oh right apparently ending their
partnership with a model in 2017
because she spoke out against white
supremacy and filtering social issues
through the lens of profit
isn't just massively annoying it can
actively harm people
take maeve's sexuality you know maeve is
bi right
yeah you know what i just feel like
lesbian is a bit of an easier cell but
more cut and dry
clearly vods preoccupation with gay
rights is just another sales tactic
not an earnest means of celebrating
maeve for who she actually is
the company then tries to overhaul the
image of maeve's pretend partner elena
so she can better conform to the
stereotype of what
a lesbian should look like that looks
like menswear pew research shows that
two feminine women in a relationship
sends a problematic message
this is the danger of virtue signaling
as marketing strategy
it puts a corporate friendly face on
social causes thus obscuring
the actual reality people are then
bombarded with images that reinforce the
big business version of reality
and this sort of corporate do-gooding
often provides a useful and deliberate
distraction from a given business's
less savory practices this is well
documented in fran hawthorne's ethical
sheik
in vott's case all the feminism and gay
pride distracts people from the reality
that the company is a private military
contractor with a
less than stellar human rights record in
this way we might better appreciate the
boy's most
glorious jab at marvel for context in
season 2
vaught is going all in on female
empowerment with their new pr campaign
girls get it done can you tell us a
little about how girls get it done girls
get it done
girls get it done girls get it done the
idea is that since there have never been
three women in the seven before now's
the time to cash in on not being sexist
anymore
but for all the congratulatory talk
female empowerment is pretty much the
exact
opposite of what vaut is actually about
for starters its newest film the dawn of
the seven
isn't exactly concerned with portraying
realistic female characters
you write all women is either unknowable
hitchcock [ __ ] or michael bay
dolls i mean i get that a lifetime of
jerking off to transformers didn't
exactly make you popular with the ladies
but
um a little effort would be nice that's
a literal nazi saying this
and it's not like the company has
embraced girl power off the screen
either
recall our coerced into spandex
starlight
i'm fine with my old outfit we're not
all of which brings us to
that marvel scene to summarize there is
one very notable moment in avengers end
game when peter parker asks captain
marvel how she plans to get past the
incoming onslaught of badminton in
response the scarlet witch and okoye
pop in and say don't worry
she's got help as more female heroes
swoop in to help
when i saw it tons of kids went ape
because marvel was finally letting their
female hero
shine but for more jaded adults this all
felt a little forced exactly the kind of
corporate feminism that we've become
wary of and the boys
seem to agree mimicking marvel's scene
in the dawn of the seven
how are you gonna get through all of
them don't worry
girls get it done much like vaught
celebrates their girls get it done after
years of being a total boys club
marvel's scene
is a weird victory lap for a company
that waited a whole decade before
putting out its first standalone female
superhero film
captain marvel which also happens to be
a movie that many have called a thinly
veiled recruitment tool for the
air force you're so cool
and that's not by accident the u.s
military has often exerted
editorial influence over movies like top
gun or captain marvel
in exchange for access to sick tanks and
planes the result
a scrappy but not too rough around the
edges hero who can be turned
both into a toy line and an
advertisement for the us military
that spirit of her that sense of humor
mixed with total capability and whatever
challenge comes her way
is really what air force pilots are like
the kind of hero who would never
ever do something like kick a person
while they're down and yell
see in the brand safe virtue signaling
realm of corporate social justice
everything has to play well with a large
audience and so all the corporations
who sponsor pride parades want to ignore
that the first pride was actually a riot
incited by police brutality or how those
who vaguely stand against
hate on instagram never want to go into
the details about what that actually
means
but the boys does it looks like this
three women
giving a bloody beat down to a literal
nazi
yes two cases also congrats marvel
you've been roasted now a common problem
with the way the word
virtue signaling gets thrown around is
that the term seems exclusively used
against the left
so a sensible question would be is
virtue signaling confined to the liberal
sphere
and the answer to that is absolutely not
we just don't usually
think about it in those terms to see
what i mean let's look at the king of
conservative virtue signaling himself
homelander if virtue signaling is the
invocation of issues or values out of
self-interest rather than genuine
concern
then this is homelander's patriotism to
a t
the dude does not give about america or
american citizens
but he goes to great lengths to seem
like he has a raging hard-on for the
troops in the land of the free
oh and uh you guys
you are the real heroes
not only that our sociopathic soup is
very careful to invoke all those
cheesy patriotic platitudes when
addressing crowds
and introduce it to a little thing
called god's judgment
that's what i think
sounds like the american thing to do
this rhetoric we might add is common to
all politicians but especially those on
the right
but if you've served with our amazing
soldiers like i have
you would know that freedom comes at a
price
of course this is the same guy who
downed a whole airliner of american
civilians before casually flying off and
letting them sink to their watery graves
to see how shallow all this patriotic
posturing really is
you need only to look at what gets
homelander upset
not the deaths of innocent americans but
rather those rare moments when he isn't
showered with love and adoration for
example when people come after
homelander for
accidentally killing an innocent
bystander we see the strongest man in
america
break down hard
of course a homelander isn't alone when
it comes to virtue signaling via
patriotism
vots is arguably just as bad on one hand
the company turns out pro-military ads
like this one
we're proud to fly alongside them and
now we could use your support
that's right maeve with our new campaign
saving america
sort of like that captain marvel at
right on the other hand a stormfront so
rightly points out
it's all a farce oh fyi not a real base
see like homelander vaught isn't
interested in actual
national security or supporting the
troops all they're interested in is
those sweet sweet military contracts
and there is only one company that has
the product
to fight back and to that end vaught
does everything from blackmail sitting
senators
to imprisoning and experimenting on
innocent civilians with compound v
real good job keeping america safe
there's also a kind of christian virtue
signaling
you know pastors who get rich and famous
for signaling to the world how much
they love jesus even if they're sleaze
bags preaches all that
pray the gay away now he's the meat in
the mandage
like that and finally there's what i
call authenticity signaling which is all
about broadcasting how
real you are as best embodied by
stormfront
be a [ __ ] if you want be whatever just
drop the mask once in a while
feels good of course her persona is also
carefully crafted
meant to rile up her base for her own
gross ends
but because she defines herself in
opposition to her squeaky clean heroes
her own performance of
realness finds a receptive audience as
if homelander and maeve are gonna eat
mres and piss in a ditch with the rest
of the crowd
with all this virtue signaling coming
from both the left and right
from individuals to corporations you
might be asking yourself
one simple question how the did we get
here
virtue signaling even if it wasn't
called that is quite old
they even complain about it in the bible
when jesus said you needed to
shut up on facebook about buying a
stranger starbucks
well i'm paraphrasing but that's
basically what he's saying
but our current virtue signaling
hellscape may be at least partially
the result of one industry public
relations or pr
ever since ivy lee the founder of modern
pr
first repaired the rockefeller family's
robber baron image through
heavily slanted press releases and a
highly choreographed sympathy tour
through colorado
the world wised up to the fact that a
little positive publicity goes a long
way
of course people maligned lee as a hired
slanderer
and poisoner of public opinion and maybe
they had a point
because here's the messed up thing
wisecrack a hundred years ago
lee opened up the floodgates and now the
field of positive spin can be used to
rehabilitate the image of just about
anyone
or anything and that's where things get
dark
to see what i mean let's look at the
messed up journey of the guy you love to
hate
the deep aka aquaman except he does
sexual assault
after being booted from the seven for
sexually assaulting starlight the deep
spirals hard eventually getting some
time in the clanker for commandeering a
kid's water park i think water's
supposed to be fun
try swimming in the mariana trench
little idiots
when he's bailed out though it's by the
church of the collective who in exchange
for his bank account
agreed to do some serious pr work to get
him back into the seven
to that end the church makes the deep
appear in some seriously cheesy
infomercials and even focus test a wife
for him
but i thought i got to choose you do and
you're choosing cassandra
now the running joke of the season is
how truly pathetic the deep is and how
willing he is to go along with a pr
blitz that presents such a patently
false
image but underneath the humor we have
to realize how
fundamentally screwed up all this is
through the persuasive dark arts of pr
the deep a repeat sexual offender and
all around
nearly regains his position in the most
prestigious paramilitary organization
in the world did you catch malala you
subsidized tweet called your sweetheart
but she's a sweetheart but if you think
it's terrifying that pr can rehabilitate
a piece of
like the deep then you're going to love
this next one the boy shows how pr and
all its virtue signaling
can even make nazism look kosher to
understand what i mean
let's look at homelander and his new boo
stormfront
by understanding the ins and outs of pr
stormfront is able to revitalize
homelanders flagging all-american brand
you don't need 50 million people to love
you you need
five million people [ __ ] pissed you
have
fans i have soldiers
another word stormfront and true don
draper fashion
knows how to sell a message to the
masses basically
homelander takes all that patriotic
virtue signaling he's known for
and appends it to a violently xenophobic
message
and the results are downright terrifying
one
nation under god remember
right before these godless inhuman super
villains started pouring across our
borders
and dragging us down into their mud of
course it goes without saying
that neither homelander nor stormfront
cares about the supposed super terrorist
threat
a threat we might add that was literally
created by homelander himself
has ever occurred to you that a suit
terrorist showing up
exactly when we needed him to was
pretty incredible coincidence instead
all this spin serves the purpose of a
larger darker message
a race war led by ava braun over here
they want to wipe us from this earth
just because of the color of our skin
really
it's called white genocide see
stormfront intuitively understands that
if she wants to sell her vision of
white is right she needs to dress it up
with all that classic
american apple pie virtue signaling or
in her own words
people love what i have to say they
believe in it
they just don't like the word nazi it's
also interesting to consider that
stormfront's own brand of realness
is just another cynical way to brand
herself while vaught might traditionally
favor the more buttoned up approach of
giving speeches with talking points
she prefers crafting a more unpolished
brand but a brand
nonetheless paying people to make memes
and packaging people's bigotry
oh this is just the first batch i'll
have logan punch up the fear
logan my meme queen now the trouble with
virtue signaling is that
many sociologists and philosophers have
said that basically
everything we do is a performance
whether you're going to church pursuing
a career or
getting a sweet new set of truck nuts
everything we do is filtered through how
we think
others will perceive our actions well
hey as long as you're trending
right if starlight wants to do good and
be recognized for it
it doesn't necessarily make her good
deeds worthless the problem the boys
wants to remind us
is when people weaponize good acts to
distract from their evil acts
and with the world full of marketers and
pr reps it's often hard to tell the
difference
so it's just business tonight when
mr butcher in history has it ever been
about anything different
but what do you think wisecrack is the
boys right can we even begin to decipher
what's real anymore and does it even
matter
smash that subscribe button like
homelander is okay we can't show that
don't forget to ring that bell huge
thanks to all our patrons for your
support and as always thanks for
watching
later
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
bye